じゃあ集中力を育てる方法
方法一 無関心をやめて関心を持つ人間になる
日常のことをつまらないと怒りを作るのではなく
何でも真剣に面白く行う
何かをするとき やりたい
やりたいから やりたいかやりたくないではなく
必要かという基準で判断する
何あんたやりたいかやりたくないどうでもいいんです
必要かないか 決して自分でこれだけはやりたくないと言ってはいけません
集中力なくなるんです
やりたいかやってやりたくないか
そんなのはどうでもいいんだよと
必要かないか その基準が必要です
次に無関心を育てる これ矛盾でしょ
初めは関心と言ったんですけどね
初めは関心と言って 次は無関心と言うんです
両方必要です 感情的なことに
不必要なものに無関心になる
だから関心を育てながら無関心も育ててるんです
それによって集中力になるんです
関心というのは必要なものなら
もうほんのつまらないことにすごく興味を持つ
すごいことであっても
必要でないものははい
無関心 さようならと 本を読むと思ったら
もう誰かが面白い映画あるんだから見ましょう見ましょうと言ったっても
無関心ということでございます
方法二 理性 論理的に具体的に物事を観察すると理性が現れるんです
悪いことを正当化するためにも論理を使用する場合はあるが
その時必ず固定概念があって
それを無理に正当化しようとするのです
正しい論理は悪いことをするために使用できません
だから理性を育てましょう
理性はもう断然的に良いものなんです
理性で屁理屈で悪いことを正当化することはできません
あれは理性でも論理でも何でもないんです
人殺しに聖書を持っていくことは
十字架を持って戦争に行くことは
そして植民地を作ることは
こんなのは悪魔の行為で悪いことに決まってるんです
理性ならもうすごく素晴らしく正しいんです
とにかく理性で結構集中しますよ
理性というのは面白いんです
方法三 瞑想するんです
で 貪瞋痴と関係のないシンプルなことを念じてみて
走り回っている思考をストップするんです
瞑想っていうのは この勝手に走り回っている心をストップさせるんです
ちょっと落ち着けと それだけのこと
落ち着いてもらうために
何かシンプルなことを仕事させるんです
シンプルなこと そのシンプルなことは貪瞋痴で関わりは持ってはいけないんです
慈悲の思考 呼吸瞑想 無常の観察
不浄の観 不浄観などが良い対象です
そういう何かを観察する
考えたりする 念じたりする
するとすぐ思考のあの荒波がすごくなくなってくるんです
なくなって 一つのことを冷静に考えることができて
もうみるみるうちに集中力が生まれてくるんです
集中力が生まれると楽しくてたまらないんですよ
そうするとなおさらやりたくなるんです
それですごい簡単にサマーディ状態が生まれます
音楽 踊り マントラ ハタヨーガなどは良くない
サマーディは現れない
理性が沈む じゃあ音楽を聴いて集中力を育てようとやってはいるんで
やらないでください 落ち着く程度でいいんですけど
サマーディが生まれませんし
結構良くない 踊ったり
ハタヨーガやったり インドでよくやってますけど
全部ダメなんです あんなのは
より汚い欲張り人間になるだけで
はい それで終わり 終わるみたいですね
なんとか終わりました
どうもありがとうございます
時間ですね  はい